- Bladesmiths, welcome to our
strength test
the bicycle frame chop.
Now, what I'm
going to do is take
each of your canister
Damascus knives,
and I'm gonna deliver
several very brutal strikes
to these bicycle frames.
Tony, you're up first.
Are you ready?
- Let's get it on.
- We're going to.
TONY: Chopping a bicycle frame
is an extremely violent test.
My biggest concerns
are the grain
may be too big and
susceptible to breaking.
[grunting]
[exhales]
Well, Tony, the
blade stayed aligned.
But you've got several rolls.
Some little pieces are missing.
But other than
that, that held up.
Good job.
Thank you.
How are you feeling, Rebel?
As ready as I'll be for this.
[laughs]
I'm feeling a little
worried because my pins
are not all the way
through my handle
because I had rushed on it.
And so one of the
slabs could pop off.
OK, Rebel, your knife held up.
What I really liked
though was your handle.
Though it's on the
little rough side--
I mean, you've got the
pins coming through here--
but it was very comfortable.
Chuck.
Let's do this.
I'm a little concerned
about his swinging technique
and breaking my blade.
But I've done
everything I can do.
My only real
concern is I may not
have addressed all the handle
issues that the judges wanted.
[grunting]
Nice.
Well, Chuck, your
blade held up very well.
You do have some minor chipping
up at the front end here
and a little bit of rolling
on the main belly part.
But the problem I
have is the handle.
As I was chopping,
it's constantly
wanting to turn in my hand.
Bladesmiths, now
it's time to find out
if there's any sharpness
left to your edge.
Now, unlike the
strength test, this
is all about what the
edge of your blade
will do to these inner tubes.
Tony, you're up first.
You ready?
- Yes, sir.
- Let's do this.
When Doug takes the
blade, I'm apprehensive
'cause my blade took a little
more damage than the others.
Nice.
Thank you.
OK, Tony, let's talk
about your blade right here.
The blade configuration slices
through these inner tubes.
You don't have a flare over here
that might want to go through.
But overall, your
blade will cut.
- Thank you.
- Good job.
Hey, Rebel, how are you feeling?
- Good.
Let's do this.
[music playing]
Nice job.
All right, Rebel, let's
talk about your blade here.
First up, it's got the
cleanest cut so far.
Your handle
construction is smooth.
But most importantly,
your blade will cut.
Thank you.
All right, Chuck, your turn.
You ready for this?
I'm ready.
Let's do this.
I see the other two
smiths' blades cleanly
sliced through the inner tubes.
My edge was left
intentionally fat to take
the abuse of the frame chop.
Hopefully, this
doesn't send me home.
[music playing]
All right, Chuck, let's
talk about your blade.
You've got an edge
over here that lends
itself to slicing and chopping.
But overall, it will cut.
Good job.
Thank you.
Bladesmiths, the
judges have deliberated
and made their final decision.
The bladesmith leaving
the forge is Tony.
Your blade did not make the cut.
David Baker's
gonna tell you why.
Tony, you made a great
comeback in round 1
and managed to finish
a blade and get
it to pass one of the
toughest strength tests
I've ever seen on this show.
But in the end,
your blade took more
damage than the other smiths'.
And that's why we're
letting you go.
I understand.